19-22 is a Netflix adaptation of the
novella of the same name by the
acclaimed author Stephen King the
historical horror movie stars Thomas
Jane in a transformative role that
centers around a farmer's relationship
with his son after both participate in
the murder of his estranged wife
horrifying gory and haunting the film
seems very straightforward however there
is a lot more beneath the surface and
many viewers maybe lack asking questions
at the movies close throughout this
video I will be discussing the symbolism
of the rats and whether the ghosts were
real or hallucinations
the latter tying into whether Wilfred
killed himself or was murdered the
symbolism of the rats throughout the
film Wilfred is plagued by rats
historically rats have brought famine
plague and pestilence and are viewed as
vermin able to be stamped out much in
the same way that Wilfred wife was
initially appearing to vacate the corpse
of his wife they can be viewed as a
clear extension of her anger from beyond
the grave the growing number of rats at
stalk Wilfred highlight the decay of his
wife's body without having to show it
explicitly as Wilfred's guilt takes over
his mind so do the rats his land farm
house and even son's body
we start with one rat inside the mouth
of his wife something he reels and
disgust at another is caught gnawing on
the livestock within the barn
and from here they escalate in numbers
though he feels the barn attack is a
violation he too viewed the herd so
menial that a flippantly killed one is
part of the cover-up the rats are no
different to him but seeing it play out
repulses him they prey on what he's done
something made tangible when he's bitten
and his hand is amputated a constant
reminder of his misdeeds but guilt
remains and so the pat groves nibbling
at his conscience even when he's far
away from the scene of the crime
when Wilfred is in the hospital after
amputation he has a clear opportunity to
admit that he murdered his wife but when
he lets the police believe that a Jane
Doe was instead his estranged partner
the film doesn't go as far as the book
in that he imagines the rat seeing him
as he dies revealed in an epilogue to be
due to a self-inflicted wound but the
point stands they aren't just disgusting
creatures but discussing creatures that
reflect on him to his ultimate demise
that's why the literal nature of the
ghosts don't matter
the rats make the story more
metaphorical as is and are the real
thing haunting Wilfred or were they just
rats
what makes Kings work so breathtaking is
that the rat can also be viewed more
rationally first a corn farm like
Wilfred's tends to have rats so it's
necessary to keep a strict waste control
to prevent the site from getting
infested by rodents when Wilfred through
his wife into the well and piled on top
of her corpse a cow the rats had a good
source to feast upon and due to this
were able to reproduce in greater
numbers it's not surprising that the
farm including the barn and house from
this point on were filled with rodents
Wilfred initially believed that this
invasion of rats could be the result of
his guilt however we do see on a couple
of occasions the character taking
hysteria pills if you research this type
of medicine they were prescribed for
women at the time and contained a
mixture of opiates cocaine and
chloroform which consumed in large
quantities generate hallucinations on
the patient so you can admit that much
of what Wilfred saw was due to the side
effects of taking these hysteria pills
combined with alcohol where the ghosts
real Stephen King's work is heavily
steeped in the supernatural throughout
his rich body of work there are
thousands of examples of gulps and
specters haunting the characters that
inhabit the books that is why I'm
inclined to believe that the ghosts were
a true manifestation of the guilt that
stemmed from his one horrific decision
in the basement after being attacked by
Arlene
Wilfred recounts that she whispered to
me secrets that only a dead woman could
not this definitely confirms to me that
Wilfred was haunted as
it's the only possible scenario that
allows him to know his son's death in
advance Kings work is played with
characters who under stress are able to
visit or view higher dimensions and
Wilfred definitely fits this role did
Wilfred die at the end
whilst the book is very clear on its
protagonists fate the film is left
open-ended personally I believe that
Wilfred survives the encounters with the
spectres due to the final line uttered
by his son stating that his death will
be quick it clearly carries the
connotations of his wife's murder which
too promised to be fast but instead was
drawn out and painful to me the spectres
want Wilfred to suffer for as long as
possible and now that he has finally
confessed they will want him to take his
punishment in the living world before
succumbing to the torture that awaits
him in the afterlife
the cruelest fate of all obviously a lot
of the film is open to interpretation
and I would love to hear your thoughts
on the symbolism of the rats as well as
whether the ghosts were real or not so
please leave a comment below letting me
know if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to my channel as I produce
ending explained discussions weekly and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
films that I analyze I recently did one
on the Tomb Raider reboot which
discusses the film's end as well as what
direction I believe this sequel will
head in so make sure you check that out
next thanks again for watching this
video and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]